five
[Music]
this is a message for william de kent
this is bruce coburn mr duke mr duke
i'm calling in response to the letters
i've received from you i'm not sure how
you found me but your letters constitute
harassment so please stop sending them
you're that writer of the infernal
machine i remember it i'm pulling it off
the shelves because of the shooter from
knoxville here's the reason i never
wrote a second book the right
combination of words will make a man do
just about anything the 17 year old
killed 13 people after reading the
controversial novel the infernal machine
i have 100 of these at my house from
your driver who drives a red hatchback
these are the only vehicles our drivers
use who are you
how about the guy who read your book the
shooter from knox no he's rotten away in
a supermax prison it's not him you need
to stop writing to me okay
so what do you want with william duke
i'll answer that after you tell me what
he wanted from you he wanted to know if
i saw the same things in the book as he
did
are you saying there's a hidden message
in that book for the whole world to hear
you can't make sense out of madness now
can you bruce you've got a lot of
questions about that book in yours
i know where we are listed again we're
at the end of act two aren't we where
the protagonist reaches their limits mr
coggles the questions they sent
is there anybody who might have a score
to settle with your calendar
[Music]
who's sending the messages
if you don't know how to play them
they'll sure as hell
you